now if Donald Trump is indicted it would
create all sorts of Chaos in the
American political landscape number one
he's a current candidate for the
presidential nomination for his party
and the first question is what would be
the implications and the consequences
for his campaign for Donald Trump to be
criminally indicted would he have have
to step down and what does it mean that
he would have to would he have to
legally would he have to because of uh
public opinion of what what would that
do to the Republican ticket what would
it do to Ron desantis's chances or would
it further open the door for someone
other than Trump and DeSantis we just
don't know but it would be very chaotic
secondly
public reaction
we have said many times before that
Trump is basically right when he says I
could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and
not lose any support or at least he was
right in 2016. maybe that was also true
in 2020 is that also going to be true in
2024 not totally clear to me